Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. So there's a
shiny new Avengers clip out so I thought
it was time to do new bonus video.
And since I haven't talked about Loki
in while I wanted to talk about what he's been doing
while Age of Ultron is going on, because
the next time we're gonna see him,
you know that it's been confirmed, is
Thor 3. Idris Elba did spoil a
few things, but I won't repeat those here,
just in case you guys haven't read them
and you don't want spoilers for any the movies before Thor 3.
Most of you probably know what I'm
talking about though, I know there were
some Captain America: Civil War rumors,
I'll talk about those after I get
through Loki-Avengers-Thor 3 stuff.
So just to add some context: most you probably know Thor 3 is called Ragnarok and you're probably familiar
with the Thor clone called Ragnarok. Really, he's like an Android clone that Tony Stark created
during Civil War in the comics. That's
not gonna be what the Thor 3 movie is about.
It'll be a proper Thor movie in space.
It'll be closer to what Jack Kirby and
Stan Lee did in 'Tales of Asgard', they did a Ragnarok storyline in that.
If you have Marvel Unlimited, you can
read for free, it's a great classic story.
Loki leads an invading force against
Asgard, kinda like he did in the first Thor movie,
including the Firelord's Surtur who breaks
Asgard, most of them die
and a bunch reborn after the fact, kind of they're reinvigorating the characters.
There's a really cool story behind the
story, with respect to Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby's Ragnarok.
It has a lot to do a Jack Kirby's Fourth
World. Like basically he wanted to kill
all the Thor characters and give birth
to the New Gods, like they were gonna replace
Asgardian characters in the comics, in
Marvel comics. The rumor is the Jack
Kirby wanted to own his Fourth World
characters and Marvel wasn't down with
that, they were just doing creator for higher
stuff,
so he took them to DC. So that's why DC has the New Gods, obviously Jack
Kirby went not a great career in DC but
it is really interesting story about how
he was gonna destroy all the Thor
characters in the comics, which I thought it was pretty funny.
As you'd expect Marvels gonna take
aspects of that story in adapted into their
movie universe.
I obviously - they do is change like
little things based on characters they've
already developed or elements that
they're working with in other movies.
Like the way they changed the Guardians of the Galaxy back story, changing Ultron's
back story, you get the idea.
I know lot of you're asking like how are these phase three movies there are gonna fit
together because there's way more than of them
that there were in tduring phase 2. So what's gonna happen is some of them
will pick up in the same time line, like
even though they come out like,
you know, six months after each other,
some of them will occur in the same time frame.
So Avengers: Age of Ultron ends, Captain
America: Civil War picks up right after that
and then a couple movies later, Thor 3 also picks up right after that.
It sounds better than it is here's the
actual phase three lineup: so
Captain America: Civil War is the
beginning a phase 3, that comes right,
after Ant-Man.
Ant-Man is like the tail-end of phase 2. Then comes Doctor Strange,
Guardians 2, Thor: Ragnarok,
Avengers: Infinity War - Part 1, Black
Panther,
Captain Marvel, Infinity War - Part 2,
and then Inhumans is shutting down phase 3 before phase 4 starts.
If you guys listen to Chris Hardwick's
Nerdist podcast he just interviewed
Brian Michael Bendis
and Bendis said that he is reading phase 4 scripts right now, like they're
actually writing those movies.
So he said they're really exciting but he
could say anything about them. Just
working in reverse from Infinity War to
Age of Ultron. Infinity War is supposed to
be like where
shit goes crazy on a galactic scale,
everyone's fighting each other, big war in space.
Think that Thor 3 is like the bomb that goes off that makes everything exploded
Ragnarok is all about the idea
destruction and rebirth. So as stuff starts to
go crazy through phase 3,
there'll be, you know, sort of a metaphorical rebirth of characters,
and literally some stuff will be
destroyed and new stuff will be born out of it.
The most important person in all of this, as
you'd would expect, is Loki,
now only because he's a big part of the
original Ragnarok story,
but because he is a master at playing
both sides.
So what does he have to do with what's
going in Avengers: Age of Ultron? Well,
think about it this way: Tony Stark
takes a very notable scepter,
puts it in his lab, you know it
accidentally, helps create a sentient
robot take wants to kill everyone,
Loki needs to get that back.
If you guys remember during the Marvel
phase three announcement, Kevin Feige
did a Q&A where he
thankfully confirmed the Mind Gem is in
Loki's scepter.
That plays a big role on the creation of
Scarlet Witch, Quiksilver
and Ultron. We don't really know about
Vsion, it could have something to do
with the creation of Vision.
But there's a lot of rumors that the
Soul Gem could have something to do that too.
The only thing we know is confirmed
is Loki's scepter.
During the first Avengers movie, it was
given to him
on loan by Thanos. Thanos gave him the
scepter
and an army of Chitauri warriors in
exchange
for retrieving the Tesseract. None of those things ended up happening:
he didn't take the earth, the army was
destroyed and the scepter was left in the
possession of humans.
So at some point Thanos is going to
collect, so Loki is going to have to do
something to get that back.
While he's masquerading as Odin, Loki also has possession
or at least access, to the Infinity
Gauntlet which was last seen
in Odin's vault. I don't think we've seen
it since the first Thor movie which is
actually a long, long time ago,
so let's assume it's still there, unless
told otherwise. After the first Avengers
movie they also took the Tessaract back
there,
although it didn't seem like it was
referenced during Thor: The Dark World.
If you member the beginning of that movie,
when he first meets with Jane Foster, he
explains the relics
that predate the Universe, that was him
talking about the Infinity Stones.
There's a lot of unanswered questions as
to why Loki would wanna free Surtur,
why it'd would end up destroying Asgard, but it probably has something to do with him
in Thanos and their relationship.
Loki wants to be King of Asgard
more than anything.
He made a deal that he did not fulfill,
so maybe that's what leads to Ragnarok.
I know a lot of your asking where's Odin in all of this, what happen to him at the end of Dark World?
Anthony Hopkins said some very ominous
things, but it's all conjecture it was
just him speculating.
He made an off-hand comment saying like
you know, 'I made two films, that's enough.
I'm done I don't know what happened to
him, maybe he's dead.'
Really I think Odin is just stuck in
their version of the Afterlife
with Hela. I think that Thor: Ragnarok will deal with that idea, like the idea of
Asgardian afterlife.
Basically all the Thor things that you
wanted to see, but they haven't done in movies yet.
The reason that idea gets me really
excited because you know if Thor is
going to beat Loki in Thor: Ragnarok, it's gonna be like Thor versus Loki,
then that means that Thor might take
possession of the Odin Force by the
end, it'll become the Thor Force.
That's basically Odin's life Force. Over
the last 50 years they've
explored the powers that the Odin force gives Odin and Thor in a lot
of different ways but,
basically it is like the most powerful
cosmic force you can have next Infinity Stones,
which means it could play a big role in
Infinity War - Part 2.
Thor's rumored to be absent in Infinity War - Part, 1 but I don't think they would leave him out of part 2.
And if you're gonna fight someone who has
all of the Infinity Stones
wouldn't you want someone who is in
possession of the Odin Force? That's all
speculation but I just I feel like before
Chris Hemsworth vacates the role, like in
his last couple of films,
they're gonna elevate him to King of Asgard. In order to do that he gets to
go through this big crucible which,
you know, implies that he might die and then come back to life. It's always fun to see
older versions of Thor from the future in
the comics. He acts a lot more like Odin,
he's way grumpier, he's way less fun.
There was a comic recently the kinda bound a bunch of Thors
across space and time to fight
this one single villain.
The older Thor always tells young Thor:
'kill your brother now. Don't wait, kill
him now.'
It's so dark and so awesome. I know there were a lot of questions after like one of the
last Avengers trailers because
you see Thor thrashing around, and this
woman that looks kinda like Hela,
I think he'll hallucinate the Asgardian
afterlife,
like he'll hallucinate some Norse Gods. Scarlet Witch is going to be doing some
awesome things with their brains, so I
think that's where we'll get our first taste
of the Asgardian afterlife. But it will be
a hallucination, it won't be like Thor
actually dying,
it'll be just him hallucinating it. Speaking of Galactic War, I know everyone's wondering
what's gonna happen to Ultron at the end
of Avengers 2 because
they can't leave them on Earth 'cause he'll just inhabit other technology.
In the comics, this is actually really cool, he was the reason that the first Guardians team got together,
He started an annihilation conquest.
Because the first Guardians movie changed
a lot of their backstory,
they can still do annihilation conquest
in the future. So they could do that for
like Guardians 3.
I'm not expecting to see Ultron during Infinity War, but it is totally possible.
It's been so long since we've seen Red
Skull, that it's like, you know, once they retire
a big villain, once they beat him, usually they don't come back right away.
So here's my big question for you guys:
Loki needs the scepter,
scepter's still on Earth in Age of Ultron,
how do you think that Loki is going
to get the scepter back?
I know it all sounds a little bit complicated, like with all these phase 3 movies especially
the ideas fo Ragnarok and how it all
ties together. Don't worry though,
Marvel basically make these movies, so can go in cold.
Even if you don't read, comics, you haven't seen any the other ones,
you should be able to follow each of the
movies. I will say though
it's a lot more fun if you get Marvel
Unlimited and just go on their basic
recommendations. They do have like movie
reels words were it's like,
'hey, learn more about these stories from the movies'. Usually I try to make suggestions
like Avengers: Age of Ultron story
video they did a while ago, but just browse around, it's like the best way to
spend a Saturday afternoon.
And it's super-cheap. And just to address the Captain America rumors,
Captain America: Civil War: the rumor is
is that an Avenger
will died during Age of Ultron and they
won't be part of Civil War.
Most of the Avengers appear in Civil War, but that there's been like a lot of posters
with one notable omission,
so people are like 'oh that character is probably the one that dies, the one that's missing.'
In case you don't want spoilers, don't worry, I'm not gonna mention that character's name.
From what I've read, the rumor is born
out an old version of
the shooting script for Age of Ultron.
Personally I would just ignore it.
They actually they start shooting
Captain America: Civil War April 1st. I
know it sounds like April Fools, like it's
a joke, but it's not a joke, they are
actually shooting.
So in case you guys haven't seen it yet you can click here for my last Avengers
trailer breakdown
so much fun. We get to see the Vision  finally. Finally. And you can click here to learn
all about Scarlet Witch in the comics.
Obviously the movie's doing it a little bit
different but I tried to incorporate that into the video.
So, thank you so much for watching. I know since all you guys want high fives to come
back, I'll say high-fives, see you guys tomorrow.